Donald Trump's disapproval has exploded
in the last two weeks and there seemed
to be two big factors number one Trump's
just tragically historically disastrous
response to the recent mass shootings
and then in addition to that you've got
the continued recession fears and stock
market crashes 800 points lost on the
Dow yesterday more than a three percent
decline there and on the Nasdaq and on
the S&P 500 and Donald Trump just
continues to tweet nonsense about the
economy and about trade and about who's
to blame and the most amazing thing
about all of this is that a Fox News
poll finds that Trump is really not
doing well Fox just released a
presidential approval poll which has
Trump at 56 percent disapproval now
before I go any further it's shocking
that it's only 56 percent in other words
the fact that only sit of 56 percent of
the country disapproves of the job Trump
is doing is a real red flag about tens
of millions of people in our country but
needless to say this has now basically
tied the record for the highest Trump
disapproval the point here is the trend
line Trump's disapproval is up five full
points from last month and again it's
back to essentially statistically
matching the record high disapproval
Trump has had during his presidency
which was October of 2017 nearly two
years ago and the timing of this from an
electoral perspective could be good as
we start to get into the 2020 election
in full and meanwhile Donald Trump
continues to do nothing substantive
about economic policy obviously because
he doesn't understand it he continues to
do nothing substantive about the gun
violence issues in the United States and
the same Fox News poll found that
two-thirds of Americans this is a
significant majority in a such a hyper
partisan environment two-thirds of
Americans want a ban on assault rifles
and semi-automatic weapons this is up
seven points over the last 15 or so
months this is a very important change
we already knew background checks were
popular the Fox News poll finds that
there is 90% support for universal
background checks criminal background
checks on every gun purchase and sale
however it is across party lines
90% of Democrats want universal
background checks 90% of Republicans
want universal background checks this is
not common in the United States so
listen it's clear why Trump's approval
is dropping you have mass violence
events when Barack Obama presided over
mass violence events he would empathize
with the victims in a genuine way it's
not that much to ask for but he did it
Donald Trump attacks political opponents
doubles down on bad ideas takes smiling
thumbs up pictures with a baby just
orphaned by the mass shooting so it
makes sense but even still even though
the trendline is going towards
disapproval how does 40% of the country
still approve of the job this man is
doing how does nearly a third of the
country think that Donald Trump's
actions are pulling the country together
when the obvious reality is the opposite
of that how clueless do you have to be
to look at what's going on and come away
with that opinion so at the micro level
can we just pass background checks I
mean 90% of the country wants them can
we just get it done at the macro level
we see all of this data we see Trump's
disapproval climbing we see Trump's
polling underwater in a bunch of swing
states for the 2020 election Bernie
Biden Warren all polling ahead of Trump
and hypothetical matchups but are we
going to remove him or are we going to
blow it that's my question I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and make
sure you are getting my live streams on
twitch at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
skill share and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to skills
share when you click the link underneath
this video skill share is a vibrant
online learning community offering more
than 25,000 video classes on just about
anything you can think of get better at
playing an instrument learn to use
Photoshop how to edit videos they have
classes on drawing paint
business cooking nutrition personal
productivity and I'm not even really
scratching the surface I recently took a
great class on introductory watercolour
painting I'm still not good but I am
learning and you can access the entire
library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video